Okay, Michael so I have written out biased on upon your rather impressive way
of thinking about it. All the possible
strategies for a. And all the possible strategies
for b. A, can go left, left, left right, right left, right, right. For states
one and four respectively. And b can go Left right, middle right or right right.
>> Right.
>> Right. In particular, three in stage
three we can only go R. Which makes me a?
>> Conservative?
>> A pirate.
>> Oh. That makes more sense.
>> It does make more sense. Okay. So,
now why did I write it this way Michael?
Well, I wrote it this way because if I write it this way with all the choices,
all the strategies that b has up here and all the strategies that a have here. I
actually form a matrix. And I can put in each of cells of the matrix the value
of taking a particular from a and a
particular strategy from b. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, that's very clever.
>> Yes, it is very clever. I'm very happy that I came
up with it entirely on my own. Okay, so let's start filling
in these numbers. Or, instead of filling in the numbers ourselves, we
could ask the students to do it by making it a quiz.
>> Nice, I see.
>> Shall we do that?
>> Sure
doesn't seem very hard.
>> Okay, so let's make certain everyone here understands
and what exactly we're asking you to do. We're saying
that if for example A takes this first strategy
go left and stay one and left and stayed four.
And B takes it's first strategy which is go
left and stay two and right and stayed three. What
is the value for A that will result? So, let's
actually do the first one as an example and ask
everyone to do the rest of them. That seem fair?
>> Yeah, that's what I was going to suggest too.
>> Okay, good. So let's see. If A chooses to go left in state one, since A
goes first, we'll end up in state 2, right? And then in this first strategy. B
goes left in state two, which means we will end up going down this path and the
value there is plus seven. So seven is in fact the value of this game with
respect to A. Now we know that because this
is a two player zero sum finite deterministic game
of perfect information. That if a gets a value
of seven, b gets a value of minus seven. So
we could write minus seven here, seven comma minus
seven here. But since we know that it's equal
and opposite let's just write down the value for
a. Okay? Just for compactness-sake. That seem fair to you?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, cool. So with that
in mind, let's see if we can fill out
the rest of this table. Think you can do it?
>> I think so.
>> Okay. Then.
>> Can you give me a place to write everything?
>> It will magically appear. Go.